Good Morning John, It's Wednesday. It's Song
Wednesday, the Wednesday before The Project
for Awesome, and yesterday you made a video
about things that you love.
And I wasn't going to play this song today,
but that video inspired me to... to play a
song about something that I love.
And it's a little bit more sentimental than
my average song, but it is, about love. So
hopefully you like this despite the fact that
it isn't my usual fair.
"This song is for a girl
no wait I changed my mind
this song, is for an adult female
Is it just me or is it creepy
how often pet names refer to little children?
And it's not just girl
and it's not just baby
it's also boy and I think it's where we get
shawty.
So this song is for the adult female I love
And if there's anything she's been dreaming
of
All she has to do is ask.
And if she wants me to
I'll do whatever she asks me to do
as long as it isn't really evil
or otherwise makes me uncomfortable.
cause that's what love is, and I have it,
for her.
This song is about love
But not what we think of as love,
especially if we are Justin Bieber
Love is hard and love is messy
And it can hurt worse than fire And sometimes
it makes you want to tear down a
building with your bare hands
But it also happens to be
the best thing that's ever happened to me
And I'm obviously not a big fan of hyperbole.
So this song is for the adult female I love
And if there's anything that she's been dreaming
of
And if I can acquire it with the amount of
money I have
without making myself destitute then
all she has to do is ask
And I'll be with her until the end of time
as long as time ends before one of us dies.
cause that's what love is, and I have it,
for her. Yeah, that's what love is, and I
have it for her. Oh that's what love is, and
I have it for her. I LOVE YOU BABY!"
I hope you didn't find that too corny, and
all I have left to say is "YOUTUBE DOT COM
SLASH P 4 A!"
If you haven't subscribed, seriously, you're
going to regret it.
End screen time! Click on the Project for
Awesome logo if you haven't subscribed, go
subscribe. Also, I put some links to my old
songs up here. And of course, you can always
go see me kill people in Assassin's Creed.
Sometimes I sing songs while I'm killing people
in Assassin's Creed like "Die. Die, Die, Die,
Die, Die. Die, Die. Die, Die, Die, Die. Stab
Stab!"